uh what's up with Deadpool 3. you know
fans want to know anything uh any scoop
yeah what is Apple Deadpool three that's
a really good question
I have to be very diplomatic about what
I say here
um
I'd like to be in it they have called me
about being in it
um right now we have not agreed
on terms
um and everybody's trying their best and
doing their best
it may not it may or may not work out I
don't know
I don't know all right
um but you're an integral part of that
you know serious would you call it a um
I'd like to think so I do think that
this movie
um since the requirement of you know
this Deadpool Universe by Marvel Disney
all that thing all that merger that
happened I do feel like
they're trying to reinvent it a little
bit I think this movie is going to be
much more about
um Wolverine and Deadpool
um and that's known right that's not a
secret
yeah yeah that's known yeah he's I mean
who he was going to be a huge part of it
and I'm sure he'll be great
now do you and Ryan ever just text each
other like hey congratulations on that
or hey what's up how are you yeah I do
it all the time whenever he has children
which now is a lot of them I'm always
congratulating him on that
um I also do get called a lot too he's
he has a lot of honors he's a lot of
like he was being honored by
organization whatever the [__] they're
they're called and then there was like
some Canadian award and they wanted
they've been wanting me to like do
videos non-stop for that stuff and I'm
like Ryan one more and I'm done that's
it
but I love him I really do he's a great
guy he's a really um
straight shooter hard worker
[__] funny as [__] and he's there for
you when you're doing your lines when
you're he's he's right there
because some actors yeah you know
they're not they're you know yeah yeah
he's
yeah he's very um he's present and
and a team player he's
he's trying to improve you know like I
don't I'm not a
a sensitive actor in that sense of like
if you have an idea for me I'd love to
hear it I you know I'll try anything
um if you're gonna make me better
fantastic
um so he's we work well together in that
way he I you know he's very Hands-On and
he's like try this so what about that or
does this make sense and you know
changing lines all the time or whatever
it's fun
really so your own it keeps you on your
toes
improv that happens a lot of improv do
you like that or do you like I'm more of
a scripted person I don't want to know
my stuff and but I don't like people
throwing [__] at me
I think depending on what you're doing
um if you're doing Shakespeare I
certainly don't want to improv that [__]
um
something like Deadpool
it's fun you know
um
especially if you know a character
really well you can have a good time but
it can also be really scary